pidgins some people love them everybody
thinks they're dirty nasty which are
actually not there dub oh they are stubs
without other people not so much I hate
them they get way too close I don't let
people into the personal space that
pigeons get into they're just aggressive
but whatever your stance may be if you
live in a city you have to deal with
them while pigeons are clearly at home
in American cities like New York they're
actually native to seaside cliffs
halfway around the world in North Africa
the Middle East and Europe where we
domesticated them five thousand years
ago at first we found them for a source
of protein like chicken then we bred
them as messengers in the eighth century
BC for example the Greeks used pigeons
to send results from the Olympic Games
to nearby towns and by the 16th century
pigeons had reached the ultimate peak
hobbyists began breeding the birds for
show Akbar the great for example
reportedly had 10,000 show pigeons in
his personal collection suffice it to
say humans and pigeons were inextricably
linked and that's why Europeans who
migrated to North America in the 1600s
brought some of these birds with them
and surprise surprise they escaped and
that's kind of what formed these feral
populations and cities around the world
that's biologist Elizabeth Carlin who
studies pigeons at Fordham University
once pigeons escaped their population
exploded especially in cities because as
Carlin says cities are essentially
tailor-made for these birds for one
pigeons can thrive on human food unlike
say Robbins or Cardinals what we have
here is pigeons eating it looks like
race and bagels and probably doughnuts
in there
well and that ability to consume all
this food waste has really made them
very successful in cities but it's not
just our leftovers they're noshing on we
also feed them spike at spike as a
result pigeon spent a lot less time
searching for food and a lot more time
breeding which they can actually do
without trees in their native range
pigeons nest on rocky seaside cliffs and
cities often mimic that by having tall
buildings and by having places for
pigeons to nest within that such as fire
escapes or AC units or even just ledges
that are built in decoratively on the
building all mimic those clips but
there's another reason why pigeons are
so successful in cities they're
incredible navigators some of these
birds can find the way home from nearly
a thousand kilometres away and those
navigation skills serve them well in a
complex cityscape that is likely linked
to their ability to find food within the
city and know where food sources
previously were and go and check in
those food sources so how many pigeons
live in cities anyway
in New York there's an adage one pigeon
for every person that would be more than
eight million Birds and whether or not
that's true urban nights have decided on
one thing the city isn't large enough
for the both of them I got nothing for
them I don't got food
I don't got money I got nothing leave me
alone in 2003 for example things got so
bad in New York's Bryant Park that a
professional falconer was hired to scare
them away and it's not just American
cities in Bangkok for example officials
have considered imposing jail time for
people who feed the birds but here's the
thing as long as we have thriving cities
pigeons will live in them in fact the
only thing that might control their
populations
aside from cleaning up is natural
predators for long time pigeons didn't
have natural predators within cities
that's thanks in part to the insecticide
DDT which Americans started using in the
1940s the use of DDT
eggshells very thin and decreased the
population of Raptors such as peregrine
falcons and Cooper's hawks and
red-tailed Hawks but in 1972 the
Environmental Protection Agency banned
DDT and as a result those predators are
now moving back into the city and with
so much to eat they probably won't be
leaving anytime soon
[Music]